let's have three position vectors here
in r2 let me scroll this over a little
bit let's say my first position vector
is x naught
and it is equal to
let's say it's equal to minus 2
minus 2. so if i were to graph x naught
i go minus 2 minus 2 x naught looks like
that
x
naught my next position vector i have is
x 1 and i'll say that's equal to minus 2
so far to graph here minus 2 2
that's my next position vector right
there
and this is x 1. when i say it's a
position vector they specify a specific
coordinate in r2 and let me draw a third
one just for fun
x two
let's say that that is equal to
that is equal to
two
minus 2
so if i were to draw this easy 2 minus 2
it goes right here
so that vector right there is x
2.
now what i'm curious about or i guess
not curious about what i'm what i want
to do here is define the line segments
that connect these points so let's say i
have my first line segment let me call
it l1
let me call it l naught
l naught and i want it to be the line
segment that connects x naught to x x1
how can i construct that well that's
going to be so i want to construct this
line segment right here this little let
me do it in a different color actually
let me do an orange l not so what i want
to do is i want to i want to find the
set of all of these values right here
all of the position vectors that define
points on this line right there well we
could define it as we could start off as
at x not
we could say that orange line is x
naught plus
scaled versions of the difference of x 1
and x naught right if you take x 1 minus
x naught you get this vector right there
that's x 1
minus x naught that orange vector i know
i wrote it right there so it's hard to
read but if you just take x1 minus x
naught you get that and that makes sense
x naught plus this orange vector is
equal to that blue vector so if you just
take different scaled up versions of
this guy you're going to end up at
different points in this direction right
we're taking we're starting at x naught
maybe i should do that in green
we're starting at x naught and then
we're going to add up scaled up versions
of this group of this orange vector
which is just the difference of x 1 and
x naught so let me write that so scaled
up versions of x 1
minus
x naught
now we have to constrict if we just want
to be in this line segment we have to
constrict r t if we said t was a member
of real numbers if it was any real
number then we would essentially be
defining the set of this entire vertical
line going up and down uh to infinity in
in both in the upwards direction and the
downwards direction but we just want to
restrict it to start here and then go up
here and it doesn't necessarily have any
doesn't necessarily have to have any
direction we could say this is true our
little line segment here is true for t
let me write it this way
t is
greater than or equal to zero so when t
equals zero this term cancels out and we
just have this
point or this position right here let me
do it in
we draw it in green we just have that
position there and then t is going to be
less than or equal to 1. what happens
when t is equal to 1 when t is equal to
1 this becomes x one minus x naught you
have an x naught there this exon and
that x not cancel out and you're just at
this point right there when t is equal
to one half just to make sure this all
makes sense to you what happens you have
x one minus x naught which is this
orange vector right here when t is equal
to one half you're essentially scaling
that orange vector by half and you end
up right at that point which is exactly
where you want to be you want halfway
along that line segment at t is equal to
0.25 you're going to be here t is equal
to 0.75 you're going to be there so at
any value for t being any real number
between 0 and 1 you're going to end up
at all of the points along that line
segment so that's our l naught
that's our l naught just a set of
vectors
now we could do the same exercise if we
wanted to find out
the line the equation of the line that
goes between x1
and
x2 if we wanted to find the equation of
that line we could call this l1 let me
call that l1
and l1 would be equal to
x1
plus t times x2
minus x1
for 0 is less than or equal to t is less
than or equal to 1. that's l1 and then
finally if we want to make a triangle
out of this
let's define this line right here let's
define that as l2
l2 would be equal to the set of all
vectors where you start off at x 2
x 2 set of all vectors that are x 2 plus
some scaled up sum of x naught minus x 2
x naught minus x 2 is this vector right
here so x
naught minus x two
such that zero is less than or equal to
t is less than or equal to one and so if
you take the combination if you were to
define kind of a superset let me let me
say you know if i i could have defined
my
shape
as let's say it's you know the union of
all of those guys so it's you know i
could well let me just write it l naught
l one and l two then you'd have a nice
triangle here
if you take this the the the union of
all of these three sets you get that
nice triangle there now what i want to
do in this video i think this is all a
bit of review for you but it's maybe a
different way of looking at things than
we've done in the past is i want to
understand what happens to this to this
set
right here when i take a transformation
a linear transformation of it
so let me define
a transformation i'll make it fairly a
fairly straightforward transformation
let me define my transformation of x of
any x to be equal to the matrix
1 minus 1
0 times
whatever vector x so times x 1 x 2 and
we know that any linear transformation
can actually be written as a matrix and
vice versa
so you might have said hey you know
you're giving an example with the matrix
what about all those other ways to write
a linear transformation you can write
all of those as a matrix so let's
translate let's try to figure out what
this is going to look like in what what
our triangle is going to look like when
we transform every
every point in it
so what is
let me take the transformation first
the transformation of l naught
the transformation of l naught is equal
to the transformation of this thing
right this is just one of the particular
members if you you know for a particular
t this is one of the particular members
of l naught so it's going to be equal to
the transformation
the transformation of x naught
minus the transformation of x one
minus x naught
such that
sorry minus t times x one minus x naught
that's a lowercase t not the
transformation
such that zero is less than or equal to
t is less than or equal to one let me
switch colors this just by the
properties of linear transformations
this is equal to the transformation let
me put the brackets out
of x naught
minus the transformation of our scalar t
times x one minus x naught
for all
t's between zero and one and that part
is getting a little redundant to keep
saying it
and then what is this equal to if i take
the transformation of a scaled up vector
that's just a scaled up transformation
of that vector so this is going to be
equal to
this part the transformation of x naught
minus t our scalar multiple t
times the transformation of the vector x
1 minus x naught
and then let me make sure i get my
parentheses right such that 0 is less
than or equal to t is less than or equal
to 1 and then the transformation of the
sum of two vectors is equal to the sum
of their transformations we've seen i've
seen this before so our transformation
of our first line this one right here l
naught
is equal to
the set
where it's the transformation of x
naught minus
t times the transformation of x one
minus the transformation of x
naught and we've just done our first
line so far
and i have a parenthesis there for zero
is less than t is less than or equal to
one
now this is a pretty neat result and
it's going to simplify our lives a lot
the transformation of the line that the
line segment
the transformation of the line segment
that goes from x naught to x one ends up
just being the line segment that goes
from the transformation of x naught to
the transformation of x one let's let me
make this clear what is the
transformation of x naught let's
calculate these things
so x naught was
x naught let me was minus 2 minus 2 let
me write out the transformation of x
naught
so the transformation of x naught
is equal to
let me write it out so i don't make any
careless mistakes one two minus one zero
times minus two minus two and so what
would this be equal to one minus two
minus so it's 1 minus 2 plus minus 1
times minus 2 that's going to be plus 2
so it's minus 2 plus a plus 2 so it's
equal to 0
and then we have 2 times minus 2 which
is minus 4
2 times -4 and then plus zero times so
it's minus four so that's the
transformation of x naught let me graph
it so it's zero minus four
so our x naught vector
so this is a transformation of x naught
so the
x naught the transformation associated
this vector
with this vector down here the one that
goes straight down now let me take the
transformation of the other guys
the transformation of x1 i'll just do it
right here i'm running out of space the
transformation of x1 is equal to
1 2 minus 1 0
times
minus 2 2
minus 2 two so what is this equal to
this is equal to one times minus two
plus minus one times two so that's minus
four
and then two times minus two
is minus four plus zero so minus four
minus four
so x one is minus four minus four so our
x one looks like this
our transformation of x one is that is
this vector right here in r two right
our transformation is going from r two
to r two so that's why i'm able to draw
them both on this nice
cartesian coordinate plane and we have
one left let's take our transformation
of x two
so the transformation
of x2
is equal to
our transformation matrix
1 2 minus 1 0
times
2 minus 2
and so this will be equal to
one times two is two
plus minus one times minus two so it's
two plus two is four
and i have two times two is four
plus zero times minus 2 so it's 4 4.
so x 2 is 4 4 so it's this point right
here
4 right there
x 2 is so the transformation of x 2 is
that vector right there
and so you know we are able to take the
transformation of each of these points
of this triangle but who knows what the
transformation does to everything in
between to all of these other the actual
sides of the triangle but we're able to
do a little math and we just did the
first side when we just did l naught
right there we found just using the
properties of a linear transformation
the definition of a linear
transformation actually we're able to
find that the transformation of l naught
of this
of this vertical line here
it just ends up becoming
the line where we can start off at the
transformation of x naught that's this
point that that's this the point
specified by this vector right here and
to that i add up scaled multiples of the
transformation of x1 minus the
transformation of x naught what is
this the transformation of x1 minus the
transformation of x naught the
transformation of x1 is just this vector
right here the transformation of x
naught is just that vector so this whole
term right here is just this vector
minus that vectors or it's this vector
right there
it's just that vector right there and so
what we essentially have we've defined
the same way that we did it in the first
part of this video this is just the same
thing as the line segment that connects
the point defined here and the point
defined there right we took the
difference of the two and we have scaled
up versions of that between t is equal
to zero and one so the transformation of
l naught really just became the
transformation is just the line between
the transformations of both of the
endpoints which is a pretty neat result
it makes our life simple
we can do the exact same logic to say
you know what what's going to be the
transformation
what's going to be the transformation of
l1
well l1 was the point was between the
points x1 and x2 is between
that point and that point that was l1
so using the same logic we can do the
math all over again but it applies to
any line i did it all abstractly here
the transformation of l1 is going to be
the line that connects the
transformation of the two endpoints so
it's going to be the line that connects
the transformation of x1 and the
transformation of x2 so it's going to be
so this is let me make this right here
is the transformation of l1
this right here is the transformation
of
l naught and then finally what's the
transformation of l2
the transformation of l2 l2 connects the
points x2 and x naught
so that is l2 right there so the
transformation of it using the same math
that we've done before is really just
the line connecting the transformations
of those two points
so the transformation of l2 is going to
be
equal to the line that connects the
transformation of x2 to the
transformation of x naught so it's going
to be that line right there
it's going to be that line right there
so this is
the transformation of l2 or if we
defined our our whole shape or our whole
triangle is the set of all of these the
transformation of that so the
transformation of
our whole shape
is now the skewed triangle
i think you're now getting a sense of
why this might be useful in things like
computer graphics or game development
because when you look at things from
different angles you start to skew them
and whatever else but taking this
this transformation we were able to turn
this set of vectors or the the the
positions or the i guess the this shape
which is specified by this set of
vectors right here we're able to change
it into this shape in r2 specified by a
different set of vectors but the the
whole i guess take away from this video
is you don't have to you don't have to
individually figure out you know gee
what does
what does this point right here
translate into over here all you have to
say is what were my endpoints figure out
their transformations and then connect
the dots in the same order that's what
is essentially the big takeaway from
here and this idea of when you transform
one set into another set they have some
terminology associated with it so let's
say the transformation of l naught right
l naught was the set of vectors that
specified this line
right here the transformation of l
naught we the transformation of
the transformation of l naught which is
this set is a set of vectors sorry l
naught was
l naught was this set it was the set of
vectors in our in our codomain that
specified these points this is called
the image
of l naught
under
under t and it kind of makes sense right
you can kind of you know why do they
call it the image because t is taking
t is taking this thing right here this l
naught and kind of distorting it or
creating a new image of it
in the co domain right it's taking a set
in the domain and creating a new image
of it in the codomain right there right
and we could say that
we could say that t
t of the transformation of our entire
shape
right i defined our entire shape up here
is this whole triangle right there
that's the image
and that turned into this purple
triangle here that's the image
of s
under
under t
so hopefully you found that pretty
interesting this is actually a super
useful takeaway if you ever want to
become a a 3d programmer of subtype and
the next video we'll explore what
happens when
s is no longer just a subset of our dome
of our domain right everything we've
been dealing so far l not l1 and l2 or
our entire triangle these are all
subsets of rn in the next video we'll
talk about what happens when you take
when you take the transformation of all
of rn